in fifa15 we've replicated a huge range
of emotions that players demonstrate on
the pitch and the fans experience in the
stands meaning the tone of the game can
change drastically as you play through a
match during gameplay our emotional
intelligence feature connects all 22
players on the pitch each player has a
feeling or attitude towards every other
player on the pitch which involves
positively or negatively over time based
on how the match plays out for example
if a player gets tackled or fouled
repeatedly by an opponent the player
might confront them depending on the
situation in context of the game if a
striker comes close to scoring in the
first few minutes you'll see his
teammates encourage him however if he
continues to miss the target other
players will grow frustrated and show
their dissatisfaction over time on the
other hand if he scores a last-gasp
winner for the first time ever you'll
see him get swamped by all his teammates
during our new ten player celebrations
there are now over 600 emotional
animations that will tell the story of
the match from the player's perspective
you'll witness new reactions to
decisions bad tackles
all other pivotal moments upping the
intensity of every game you play moving
now from the pitch to the stands a
dynamic match presentation feature means
games will feel even more alike than
ever before crowds will now be
distinguished by cheers and chants
designated by the club legal
you'll see in here Liverpool fans and
Phil behave differently than the fans at
La Bombonera
so commentators will they'll pick up on
specific fan behaviors triggered by
unique moments like club anthems or even
here it is again the Poznan yes quite a
sight is there Martin in fifa15 live
more celebrations than ever to choose
from we've even captured a range of
reactions from something events to the
whole stadium is getting involved this
year you'll feel the game like never
before subscribe to our YouTube channel
to see more upcoming enhancements
including player control and unrivaled
intelligence
you